[Música]
hola bienvenidos a france24 nuestro
invitado de hoy es cloud de juan el
entrenador apodado el grupo rubio brujo
rubio es de hecho el título de su libro
publicado hace poco por ediciones harto
gracias por estar en nuestro plato cumex
y el plato gracias a usted
usted tuvo una carrera profesional sólo
en francia luego se convirtió en una
especie de ave migratoria en asia pero
sobre todo en áfrica al frente de muchas
elecciones concretamente seis
selecciones africanas 19 fases finales
de la copa africana de naciones
ahora estamos en plena edición 2022 de
esta competición que se celebra en
camerún
y en camerún además
es un país que ganó la can en
1988 la pregunta que se hacen todos los
hinchas africanos pero sobre todo los
campeones es es en su opinión camerún
tiene posibilidades reales en llegar
hasta el final de liu
pues eso sí entraron bien en la
competencia con solidez no de forma
brillante pero sí sólidas bastante
eficaz y sabemos que es difícil de andar
en camerún lastimosamente para ellos
ocurrió la primera vez que organizaron
la copa africana de naciones en 1972
del congo los derrotó en casa en las
semifinales galvao por el cubo a
audiovisual pero creo que todavía
necesitan mucho trabajo en el ámbito
colectivo aunque hay que decir que el
señor infantino al haber permitido que
los jugadores llegaran sólo unos días si
el presidente de la fifa sólo unos días
antes del torneo algo que es
absolutamente inconcebible es decir que
los entrenadores no tuvieron ningún
tiempo para prepararse y que los
primeros partidos se utilizaron
finalmente como partidos de
entrenamiento y de preparación ya que no
hubo ninguna fase preparatoria como
suele pasar en la copa africana de
naciones porque hubo mucha presión para
no celebrar esta carta feria de pose
critics infantino hizo todo lo posible
para que no lo fuera por eso digo que
fue realmente el scapín de áfrica
el día de la inauguración de la carne
estuvo presente y fue abucheado y con
razón hizo todo lo posible para que la
copa africana de naciones no se
celebrará en el continente africano le
habría gustado tal vez que ciertos
eventos se hicieran en los países del
golf que es es desde el desprecio e
indiferencia o es que se obedece a los
intereses de los clubes en los que
no lo soporto porque lo he visto varias
veces me he reunido con él varias veces
cuando ha ido a áfrica y nunca habla de
fútbol solo habla de dinero y no tiene
la impresión de que trabaja para el
fondo monetario internacional- que se
pavonea de capital en capital y que
piensa que puede aprovecharse de la
codicia de los líderes africanos algunos
son codiciosos efectivamente podría
funcionar pero a la larga saldrá
perdiendo sólo una nota de mis materno
pero a áfrica hizo bien en insistir
claro claro algo que volviendo al
terreno de juego hay otro equipo que
usted entreno que nunca ha ganado la
copa africana y del que se habla como
uno de los favoritos senegal la primera
ronda fue muy difícil pero están aquí
es muy ambiguo es complicado para mí
porque apoyo a dos países efectivamente
son camerún y senegal porque les debo
mucho pienso que gané con camerún
debería haber ganado esa copa africana
con senegal creo que creo que eso habría
roto el techo de cristal que llevan
décadas intentando romper porque
deberíamos haberla ganado en 1990 o 1992
creo que tenía la mejor plantilla de las
deficiencias de juego pequeñas cosas
hicieron que cada vez llegáramos solo
hasta las semifinales y a los cuartos de
final así que eso influye mucho hay un
bloqueo psicológico entre los
senegaleses con la copa pica pero que al
psicológico se desee de gareca sigue
existiendo y destruyó la y son de madera
siguen existiendo tuvieron un arranque
difícil y tiene un equipo ni siquiera un
equipo una plantilla extraordinaria pero
creo que cuanto más avance el torneo más
los veremos emerger al más alto nivel
tuvieron algunos problemas con el commit
conway que iba y venía con el watford y
el olympique de marsella cuéllar dejó el
equipo volvió y así no fue fácil para
ellos empezar la copa africana
y
hay una particularidad en esta copa
africana de naciones y es que dos
tercios de los entrenadores si conte
bien el 16 de los 24 son africanos los
ciudadanos africanos marca esto un
cambio porque a menudo hemos visto en el
banquillo y usted es uno de ellos
obviamente a entrenadores occidentales
especialmente europeos
me da un poco de miedo este argumento
porque crea una especie de división de
los entrenadores africanos que es un
entrenador africano son mis amigos llamé
el vell marí y al jones hice los
entrenadores de argelia y senegal dos de
los tres grandes favoritos de esta
competencia más africanos que yo que he
pasado más tiempo que ellos en el
continente africano nacieron en francia
hicieron su carrera profesional que en
francia que obtuvieron sus diplomas en
francia es cierto que uno es argelino de
origen y otro senegalés así que siempre
desconfió un poco de estas divisiones a
veces un poco demagógicas que se hacen
para decir áfrica para los africanos se
habló de eso con más propiedad porque
mis asistentes locales verdaderamente
locales se convirtieron en entrenadores
después de haber trabajado conmigo que
es decir allí donde estado he formado a
entrenadores nacionales que se han hecho
cargo de equipos nacionales por lo tanto
creo que debemos tener cuidado de no
entrar en ese tipo de división es bueno
que por ejemplo admira a tu entrenador
de las comoras que hizo toda su carrera
en francia que incluso fue entrenador de
un club amateur en francia se haya hecho
cargo de la selección de las comoras
porque hace un trabajo extraordinario es
un gran logro por cierto
claro terminaron por delante de ghana
imagínense las comoras conozco mejor a
este equipo porque es el que nos sacó
con todo de la clasificación para la
copa africana de naciones
dije que era un equipo al que había que
respetar que no era un equipo de segunda
al que le reprocha vamos después de que
nos hubiera derrotado efectivamente
deberíamos haber ganado pero son un
equipo de calidad e hicieron un buen
trabajo podrían haber estado ya
clasificados si no hubiera sido por un
gol en el último minuto del segundo
partido así que hay muchas cosas que van
bien creo que lo importante sea cual sea
nacionalidad es que la gente viva y
trabaje en áfrica pero yo no voy a
volver a la historia que usted cuenta en
este libro a mediados de los años 80
dejó de ser entrenador del grenoble y se
convirtió en entrenador de camerún así
que le pusieron una trampa es que
cuando jean pierre se propuso para las
ópticas y me empujó un poco a salir el
multimillonario presidente de la época
marc región que quería multar a uno de
mis jugadores porque habíamos empatado y
yo me negué
entonces inmediatamente se crea una
división y se me pidió que me fuera y
luego por casualidad gracias al berbatov
que vivía en grenoble y fue un poco mi
maestro eugenio lea que había sido
embajador en españa e inglaterra que era
un antiguo jugador de albert pato en el
sant y tiempo y no lograba jugar en
camerún fue mi esposa la que le
respondió y él le dijo a camerún le
gusta tener a clouds camerún no quería
en realidad pero era que él le había
preguntado a albert bato por el perfil
al ver bato le había dicho creo que el
perfil ideal para un país como camerún
es un entrenador joven como claude dijo
que ya dónde era la capital más bonita
del mundo que era una pequeña parís -
embotellamientos que no había casas en
parís pero que encontraríamos en grande
eso no correspondía de todo a la
realidad llegué a camerún y
efectivamente aunque no habíamos hablado
nada en absoluto con el ministro que al
entonces sultán que acababa de fallecer
ibrahim en bombo en joya una persona
maravillosa también estaba el director
de deportes del ministerio quien anunció
ante un centenar de periodistas
de conferencias que yo era un nuevo
entrenador para un gran disgustado y mi
esposa quien no estaba al tanto igual
que yo que ella sintió que la había
traicionado el aceptar el puesto sin
habérselo dicho y el ministro después de
esta conferencia me dijo con su voz
gruesa mire entrenador tuve que decir
eso porque estábamos en una mala
situación acaban de perder 4-1 en zambia
habían quedado por fuera del mundial era
complicado así que terminé como
entrenador sin haber discutido los
términos de un contrato algo de lo que
nunca me arrepentido
bland luego pasó por muchas peripecias
fue contratado por el entonces
presidente de la república democrática
del congo joseph kabila fue a
contratarlo el mismo italia y me tuvo
que revelar si le pidió es embajador de
la república democrática del congo en
parís que se pusiera en contacto conmigo
de hecho fue la embajada de túnez para
celebrar el título de túnez en la copa
africana de naciones que el embajador
vino a verme y me dijo al presidente le
gustaría absolutamente que dirigiera al
equipo de la rdc
el mismo quien me dice volver a la rdc
por segunda vez la primera vez nos fue
muy bien pero después los contactos
con políticos desempeñaron un papel
directo a veces demasiado de ello sí por
eso es un poco mentira con de la fifa
dice que sólo es el poder del fútbol y
no de los políticos pero cuando infantil
nos llega a un país que pide sólo pide
una cosa reunirse con el jefe de estado
no con el presidente de la federación
así que los políticos juegan un papel
porque porque salva algunas federaciones
privilegiadas los demás no tienen los
medios económicos para alquilar un avión
para que el equipo pueda viajar en
buenas condiciones para reservar hoteles
para pagar los billetes de avión de los
jugadores expatriados que vienen a jugar
con la selección las federaciones no
tienen los medios así que obviamente es
el gobierno el que está detrás también
ha conocido algunos grandes jugadores
como george way entonces llegó a ser
presidente de liberia usted desempeñó un
papel clave en su contratación por el a
ese mónaco impuso su carrera
internacional samuel eto'o estamos
hablando de los líderes paso de
futbolista a ex futbolista a presidente
de la federación camerunesa qué suerte
pero también qué riesgo qué riesgos y es
un gran riesgo pero qué suerte porque el
menos sabemos que él no va a dedicarse a
calcular cuántas mansiones podrá
construir durante su mandato sino que se
centrará completamente en el desarrollo
del fútbol en camerún de raid completo
poker y del sol
por eso le dije que se centrará en la
formación de las personas en la
formación de los educadores en la
calidad de los campos de entrenamiento
en el equipo de entrenamiento en cosas
simples por ejemplo la red de protección
detrás de la portabilidad hace que las
didácticas de penalty sean más
eficientes pues el balón no termina en
un campo de caña y no se pierde tiempo
en ir a buscarlo y
eficaz así que hay que ir hacia la
eficiencia luego empezar a pensar en el
áfrica subshariana crear campeonatos
profesionales pero africanos con
realidades africanas con una metodología
africana no se trata de copiar lo que se
hace en europa o en sudamérica o en asia
hay formas de adaptar el fútbol
profesional en áfrica eso evitaría que
cientos de niños arriesguen sus vidas en
barrios en camiones sobrecargados para
aplicar a lo que ellos creen que es el
dorado que es europa que a menudo está
muy lejos de ser el dorado en equipos de
eldorado cualquier golpe que superó al
delegado club de lengua muchas gracias
muchas anécdotas para los aficionados a
la historia del fútbol en áfrica pero en
otros lugares están en el brujo rubio
publicado en francés por ediciones alto
gracias gracias y gracias a ustedes por
haber visto esta entrevista en nuestro
canal
[Música]